BEEN GREAT, THANK YOU BOTH.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP ONLY MOMENTS
AGO, HE ARRIVED AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOLLOWING HIS VISIT
ANOTHER MAJOR STORY WE ARE
FOLLOWING TONIGHT ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HE WAS NOMINATING GINA
HASPEL TO RUN THE CIA AFTER SOME
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA WERE WAITING
TO ATTACK AND WAIT UNTIL YOU ARE
THE REASON WHY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> SHE WAS INVOLVED WITH THE
TORTURE PROGRAM AFTER
SEPTEMBER 11TH AND THEN AND
INVOLVED WITH DESTROYING
VIDEOTAPES OF THE MATTER ALSO.
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE PROBLEMATIC.
>> SHE HAS A REAL HISTORY WITH
ENHANCED INTERROGATION IN THE
CIA.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE RAISING
QUESTIONS INCLUDING
JOHN McCAIN ABOUT THE FACT
THAT IN 2002, SHE RAN A BLACK
SITE CIA PRISON IN THAILAND WERE
SUSPECTS WERE TORTURED AND SHE
ALSO REPORTEDLY HER NAME WAS ON
IN ORDER FOR THE DISTRICT NO
TAPES.
BUT YOU SUPPORT HER.
>> I DO, SHE CLEARLY PRESIDED
OVER A MASSIVE ILLEGAL OPERATION
THAT VIOLATED BOTH THE U.S. LAW
AND INTERNATIONAL LAW.
I'M SURE THOSE ORDERS CAME DOWN
FROM ABOVE HER, BUT THAT IS NO
EXCUSE.
>> Sean: JOSE RODRIGUES IS THE
FORMER HEAD OF THE CIA NATIONAL
CLANDESTINE SERVICE.
HE PRAISED THE INTELLIGENCE LIKE
THE ONE THAT HASPEL RAN.
HERE'S WHAT RODRIGUEZ TOLD ME
AND 2014.
THIS IS CRUCIAL.
>> WITH THOSE OF US WHO LET THE
INTELLIGENCE COME OUT OF BLACK
SITES EVERY MORNING KNOW THE
VALUE AND BASICALLY THE
DESTRUCTION OF AN ORGANIZATION.
>> Sean: LED TO THE
WITHOUT INTERROGATION
TECHNIQUES, THERE IS NO GETTING
USAMA BIN LADEN.
SHE SAVED AMERICAN LIVES.
I WISH THE WORLD WAS AN EVIL,
SADLY IT IS.
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT, SEBASTIAN GORKA,
ED HENRY.
BY THE WAY, ED, THIS IS A
FULL-TIME GIG.
WHAT IS UP WITH THAT?
THEY'RE GOING TO OPPOSE THE
FIRST WOMAN EVER NOMINATED TO
LEAD THE CIA AND THEY'RE SAYING
SHE'S TOO TOUGH ON TERROR?
JOSE RODRIGUEZ WITNESSED THE
WATERBOARDING AND HE KNOWS THE
INFORMATION EXTRACTED.
>> THIS IS ALMOST TAILOR-MADE
FOR THEIR WHITE HOUSE.
IF THEY WERE TO DESIGN A
STRATEGY, THEY COULD SIT AROUND
AND TABLE AND SAY IF ONLY THE
DEMOCRATS WOULD ACCUSE OUR CIA
NOMINEE OF BEING TOO TOUGH ON
TERRORISTS, THAT WERE TOO TOUGH
ON TRY TO TAKE OUT AL QAEDA AND
ISIS, THAT WOULD BE EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO DESIGN AND
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING.
ON TOP OF THAT, SHOULD BE THE
FIRST WOMAN TO LEAD THE CIA.
THAT'S A WONDERFUL ACHIEVEMENT
IF SHE IS CONFIRMED AND THEN YOU
HAVE DEMOCRATS LIKE
CHUCK SCHUMER AND DIANNE
FEINSTEIN SANCTION WHEN I GET
THE JOB.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
TO BE RAISED ABOUT THOSE
TECHNIQUES.
THERE WAS THE GREAT DEBATE AS A
REMEMBER BETTER THAN ANYONE AT
THE END OF THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION, AND ALMOST
EVERYONE OF THOSE CLIPS, VARIOUS
JOURNALISTS ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE ALLEGATIONS THAT MAY HAVE
BROKEN THE LAW, BUT NOT ONE
TALKED ABOUT THE ACTUAL
INTELLIGENCE GONE FROM THAT TO
WIPE OUT TERRORISTS.
>> Sean: JOSE RODRIGUEZ
COULDN'T BE MORE CLEAR TO ME, IF
THEY DIDN'T USE THESE TECHNIQUES
AGAINST KAY SM, THAT LED TO THE
COURIERS, BEN MARTIN, LED TO ITS
KILLING BIN LADEN.
I WISH THE WORLD WASN'T FULL OF
EVIL RADICAL ISLAMIC TERRORISTS
THAT THINK THEY'RE DOING GOD'S
WILL BY KILLING INNOCENT PEOPLE,
BUT THEY KILLED 3,000 AMERICANS.
TO ME, SHE'S A HERO.
>> THAT'S WHY I WROTE THE BOOK
BECAUSE WE ARE AT WAR WITH EVIL.
THE LEFT WANTS TO ATTACK A
FEMALE APPOINTEE OF A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT.
THEY COULDN'T CARE LESS ABOUT
WHETHER WE TORTURE PEOPLE OR
NOT, THESE ARE ALL
POLITICIANS -- THEY WERE BRIEFED
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, THEY HAVE
NO ISSUES WITH INTERROGATION
TECHNIQUES, BUT ALL THEY DO.
LET'S GO BACK IN TIME.
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION IS RUN
BY A GUY CALLED OBAMA HAD A
FEMALE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
THEY WERE JUST INVOLVED IN
THINGS THAT WERE DUBIOUS WHEN IT
COMES TO INTERROGATIONS.
THIS WAS AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
HAD SOMETHING CALLED THE THREAT
TO DISPOSITION MATRIX.
A BIG iPAD ON WHICH HE WOULD
DECIDE WHICH TERRORISTS WERE
GOING TO KILL TODAY INCLUDING
MORE THAN ONE AMERICAN CITIZEN
ABROAD.
THEY WANT TO GET HIGH AND MIGHTY
WHEN THEIR PRESIDENT AND FEMALE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR ARE
KILLING AMERICANS WITHOUT DUE
PROCESS?
>> Sean: THINK OF THE
MIND-SET.
BILL CLINTON, $3 BILLION AND
THIS IS A GOOD DEAL.
I CAN'T EVEN FATHOM WHAT OBAMA
WAS THINKING $350 BILLION IN THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE CHANTING DEATH
TO AMERICA.
IN THE SAME MIND-SET, WE CAN'T
HAVE PEOPLE WHO WE KNOW OUR
TERRORISTS ABOUT INFORMATION
KILLING AMERICANS.
WE BETTER BUILD THEM SOCCER
FIELDS AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
CATER TO THEIR DIETARY NEEDS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE MIND-SET.
>> A TRAFFIC COP IN D.C. WAS PUT
IN PRISON BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
HE WAS WIRING $500 TO ISIS.
IT WAS ACTUALLY AN FBI CONTACT
AND HE GOES TO JAIL.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SENT
$150 BILLION.
>> Sean: I CAN'T EVEN
COMPREHEND HOW STUPID THAT IS.
OTHER NEWS IN WASHINGTON
TONIGHT.
>> THE OTHER BIG STORY IS
DEALING WITH THE SCHOOL SAFETY
WHAT IT'S ABOUT IS TRAINING
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL OFFICIALS TO
DEAL WITH THE THREAT.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS MAKE A
PUTTING THERE ARE NO GUN CONTROL
MEASURES, BUT LET'S REMEMBER IT
STARTED OUT IN THE -- IT'S ALL
ABOUT THE NRA AND GUN CONTROL AS
WE GOT MORE FACTS ABOUT HOW THE
POLICE DIDN'T RESPOND QUICK
ENOUGH, SOME WERE AFRAID TO GO
IN.
IT SHIFTED FROM GUN-CONTROL TO
SCHOOL SAFETY SO THAT HOUSE
PASTOR, THE SENATE STILL NEEDS
TO.
>> Sean: WHAT A DISPLAY TO SEE